Офіс Президента Зеленського хоче добитися звільнення
Віталія Кличка з посади голови КМДА.
Про цей конфлікт ми будемо говорити з Віталієм Кличком.
- Доброго дня!
Пане Кличко, офіс президента ініціював ваше звільнення з посади голови КМДА.
У зв'язку з цим ви увійшли у відкритий конфлікт з Андрієм Богданом.
Чи є у вас також конфлікт з президентом Зеленським?
Все те, що робиться, воно антиконституційне.
Це порушення закону. В першу чергу, порушення закону про столицю.
онфлікт, якого не було. Президент не може звільняти,
чи Богдан, як він подає, не може звільняти.
Тому що в законі про столицю прописано, що законодавча і виконавча влада
в місті Києва об’єднується в обличчі міського голови.
І мер міста, який виграв вибори,
повинен бути призначений головою КМДА.
Це не мій конфлікт. Я не відстоюю себе.
Мені крісло і посади не потрібні. Я відстоюю право киян
обирати владу, яка повинна бути на 100% підзвітна їм.
Які ризики виникають, якщо посади глави КМДА
і мера Києва обійматимуть різні люди?
Ступор влади - місто не зможе працювати.
Я можу знаєте, як порівняти…
Ви сідаєте в автівку, в якій є два водії,
треба кудись їхати, і у кожного є свій план,
кожен кермує в своєму напрямку.
Це може статися аварія.
Зараз я відчуваю, що йде політична боротьба за контроль над столицею.
Я зустрічався з президентом і з паном Богданом
і казав,  що нам потрібно об’єднати наші зусилля,
бо в нас багато викликів. Якщо вам потрібно боротися,
і київський міський голова вас не влаштовує,
тому що він не є членом вашої політичної сили,
то, будь ласка, давайте робити дострокові вибори.
На яких умовах Ви все ж таки могли погодитися
звільнитися з посади голови КМДА?
Фактично, це означає, що я...
залишаюся мером столиці, кияни очікують від мера подій,
але я не відповідаю за інструменти реалізації
очікувань,  які надали мені кияни,
зміни в місті. Тобто я стаю "англійською королевою",
але тим не менше несу відповідальність, а це неправильно.
Якщо все ж таки дійде до того, що буде призначений
головою КМДА, приміром, Олександр Ткаченко,
Ваші дії.Чиготові Ви до співпраці?
Я буду звертатися до судів,
до міжнародної спільноти, тому що це руйнування самоврядування.
Я розумію, що в нас є конфліктне законодавство,
воно не оптимальне. Таку ж саму річ зробив Янукович,
коли не мав кандидата на посаду київського міського голови,
він відсторонив мера, призначив свою людину,
і місто жило без мера майже три роки.
До чого це призвело? До Революції Гідності.
Андрій Богдан стверджував, що йомунібито пропонували хабар,
аби ви залишились на посаді голови КМДА.
Ви вимагали назвати прізвища. Чи знаєте ви вже ці імена?
Зараз йде війна по дискредитації мене,
як київського міського голови.
Якщо пан Богдан - голова офісу президента розповсюджує чутки
чи може правдиву інформацію, я не знаю, я вперше про це почув,
що хтось йому пропонував такий величезний хабар!
20 мільйонів доларів!
Я звернувся до НАБУ і вимагаю провести розслідування.
Таку людину я не уповноважував. Я вперше почув від пана Богдана.
Нехай він надасть факти, зроблять це розслідування.
Якщо це неправда, хай вибачається.
Якщо правда, то таких людей треба притягнути до відповідальності.
Ви у свою чергу заявляли, щоофіс президента Зеленського хоче,
щоб Ви свої дії узгоджувализ окремими людьми.
Можете сказати, що та з ким Ви мали б узгоджувати?
Мені зателефонували по закритому спецзв’язку - пан Богдан.
і запропонували узгоджувати свої дії з паном Ткаченком,
який є головним продюсером каналу "1+1".
Друга людина, яка працювала тут, був звільнений, це Вавриш.
Він відомий забудовник.
Ми знаємо, що проекти, які є в місті Києві,
також є спільними пана Ткаченка та пана Вавриша.
Я запитав пана Богдана, що я готовий координувати дії,
якщо він зможе назвати, яку офіційну посаду ці люди займають.
Якщо вони не займають ніяких офіційних посад,
тоя як київський міський голова не буду звітувати перед людьми,
які відповідальності не несуть.
Богдан також закидає вам, що ви не контролюєте Київраду
і що ви нібито визнали, що справді вимушені домовлятися з так званими "смотрящімі".
Кого має на увазі пан Богдан ?Чи взагалі такі "смотрящіє" існують?
Гарне питання до пана Богдана. Ще раз хочу сказати,
що Ви знаходитися в кабінеті мера.
Я особисто відповідальний за це місто.
І жодна людина , яка приймає рішення замість мера,
в місті не існує. Все інше,вибачте, мене будь ласка, це брехня.
Чи можете ви зараз чітко сказати, що Ви контролюєте Київраду?
Київраду контролювати неможливо,тому що в Київраді
є представники різних політичних сил, ми домовляємося.
Якщо виникають конфлікти, якщо виникають непорозуміння,
ми сідаємо за круглий стіл. І протягом останніх 5 років
в нас ніколи не було протистояння. Ми завжди знаходили точки дотику.
Під час цього конфліктузнов виникла ця тема "віденських домовленостей"
між Вами, олігархом Фірташем, Льовочкіним та Порошенком
квітні2014-ого року. Що Ви нібито отримали
відповідно до цих домовленостей посаду голови КМДА.
Зараз треба домовлятися з олігархом Коломойським?
Це брехня. Посаду КМДА я отримав тільки після того,
як виграв мерські вибори.
Домовлятися з кимось призначити -
якщо кияни тебе не обрали, неможливо.
Це також маніпуляція. Не таємниця, що пан Богдан
довгий час працював з паном Коломойським, був його адвокатом.
Не таємниця, що канал 1+1, який
співпрацює довгий час з новою командою.
І не таємниця, що в Україні на сьогоднішній день,
на жаль, залишилася велика залежність від впливових людей,
яких називають олігархами, які контролюють великі фінанси і медіапростір.
До речі, Богдан назвав також вас серед кандидатів на посаду голови КМДА.
Як Ви це розцінюєте?
Я розцінюю це так, що він розуміє,
що, знявши чи-то не призначивши Кличка на цю посаду, він порушує закон.
Ви стали фактично єдиним з попередньої влади, хто пішов
на відкритий конфлікт з Зе-командою. Чи плануєте або маєте таке бажання
об’єднатися з іншими політичними силами, які теж не вдоволені?
Я не йду на конфлікт. У мене є можливість жити в Німеччині,
США, в будь-якій країні світу.
Я хочу жити за тими самими стандартами, які є в європейських країнах,
у себе вдома. І взяв на себе завдання змінити країну,
тому я стояв на Євромайдані. Тому я захищав
європейський, демократичний вибір кожного.
Це мої принципи і за них я буду боротися.
Що саме відповіли Олегу Ляшку
на його пропозицію про об’єднання зусиль проти, як він висловився,
проти "зеленої чуми"?
Я отримав інформацію з соціальних мереж.
Розмови в мене з ним на цю тему не було.
Я думаю, краще такі питання ставити пану Ляшку.
Колишній заступник голови адміністрації президента Януковича
Андрій Портнов намагається ініціювати кримінальні справи проти вас.
Йдеться, зокрема, про нібито розкрадання київської землі.
Що ви можете відповісти на такі закиди?
Я можу сказати, що це зроблено виключно для медіа-ефекту.
Привернути увагу і поставити Кличка в негатив.
Землю розкрадати неможливо. Для цього потрібно пройти всі комісії.
Для цього депутати Київради повинні проголосувати,
отримати висновки департаментів, які відповідальні за це.
І це все абсолютно прозоро.
Я переконаний, що ці закиди, вони, як мильна бульбашка, лопнуть.
І ви побачите в наступні дні, вже нічого не буде.
Напередодні Андрій Порнтов сказав, що Вас нібито допитали в ДБР.
Можете це підтвердити чи спростувати?
Мене не можуть допитувати. Я проходжу як свідок.
І в мене можуть тільки брати свідчення.
Пан Портнов - це представник Януковича,
який 5 років сидів в Росії і зараз повернувся.
І, на жаль, така тенденція, що багато людей, які тоді
були відповідальні ібули в команді Януковича,
зараз повертаються. Це нагадує помсту.
Помсту за те, що їх усунули
Помста, що країна тоді вибрала проєвропейський шлях розвитку.
Тільки з цим я це пов’язую.
Чи можна вважати, що є загроза, що Україна
не буде йти проєвропейським курсом?
Є така загроза. Це не таємниця,
Росія робить все для цього.
І можу сказати, що будь-яка дестабілізація
може призвести до закінчення існування України.
Ключова відповідь і нашим друзям, і нашим ворогам,
я багато разів казав, наш успіх.
І нам потрібно всім представникам, які знаходяться в Україні,
робити все, щоб покращувати рівень життя людей.
Можете назвати три найважливіші Ваші досягнення на посаді мера Києва?
Ключове:
місто Київ - острів благополуччя
у порівнянні з іншими депресивними регіонами.
Відсутність безробіття, найвищі заробітні платні
в крані і найбільші інвестиції.
Що Вам не вдалося зробити? Що завадило цьому?
У мене багато планів, що я хочу зробити.
З острова Гідропарк я хочу зробити український Диснейленд.
Ми вже на шляху до цього, і я це зроблю.
Я добудую міст - Подільсько-Воскресенський, який будується більше 20 років.
До кінця наступного року ми плануємо автосполучення між правим і лівим берегом.
Дуже радий , що Київ входить
до десятки інноваційних міст світу –
розумнеsmart-city, яке ми розвиваємо.
Досягнень багато, але ще більше в нас залишається
викликів, які нам потрібно подолати.
Напередодні ви зустрічались з екс-мером Нью-Йорка,
а нині адвокатом Трампа Джуліані.
Про що йшлося? Можна вважати,
що в конфлікт входить велика політика?
Ми знайомі з паном Джуліані вже 15 років.
Він завжди підказує, дає поради,
він є великим другом України.
Ми дійсно спілкувалися про Україну, про реформи,
спілкувалися про самоврядування.
Тобто дискусія була про події в Україні.
Ви зараз не шкодуєте про те,що фактично
відмовилися балотуватися на посаду президента в2014-ому?
В2014-ому дивно б виглядало, коли люди,
які стояли по один бік барикад,
починають боротися один проти одного
в той момент, коли йшло захоплення Криму,
Донецька, Луганська, а хтось змагається за владу.
Я був переконаний, і звернувся до усіх,
ми повинні підтримати найрейтинговішого кандидата,  який має великі шанси
виграти в першому турі. Я переконаний до сьогодні,
що я прийняв у той момент правильне рішення
Якщо ні, то хто знає, проект "Новоросія"
міг би бути не тільки в Луганську чи Донецьку.
Чи є у Вас натхнення продовжити політичну кар’єру?
Чи можливо, Ви хочете залишити цю політичну арену
і перейти на спортивну?
На спортивну?
Всьому свій час.
Я в спорті з братом все що можна було, зробили.
І олімпійські золоті медалі,
і пояси Чемпіонів світу.
Навіть ми зібрали усі пояси, які тільки були.
Відверто хочу сказати, ця робота дуже тяжка.
Вона невдячна.
Але я отримую велике задоволення, коли люди підходять і кажуть "дякую ".
Це надає сил.... Я знаю, що ніхто
на моїй посаді краще б не зробив. Працюю 24 години на добу.
Коли прийде новий уряд, може  бути прийняте рішення
про нового голову КМДА. Чи готові Ви? Що будете робити?
Я краще може , ніж хтось інший,
знаю одне правило:
без боротьби перемоги ніколи не буде.
Я буду боротися.